merci d'être avec nous il est 20h40 on
est en direct merci d'être là et on va
avir encore deux témoignages incroy
enfin un témoignage incroyable et là on
va reparler bien sûr on va être dans le
dans le débat je sais que vous
l'attendez he ce débat le rassemblement
national n'a pas sa place à la marche
contre l'antisémitisme selon Olivier
verérrant il y aura une marche donc qui
sera organisée dimanche à Paris cette
mobilisation a été saluée et soutenue
par la majorité mais aussi par l'extrême
droite et Olivier verérrand estime que
le rassemblement national n'a pas sa
place à cette marche qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
ou pas avec Olivier Verand ou oui ou non
c'est parti petit regardez Olivier
verérrant et ils sont avec nous justuse
après ce parti le rassemblement national
par la voix de son président Jordan
Bardella a eu l'occasion il y a quelques
jours de couper avec son histoire nous
avons entendu ce qu' dit Jordan Bardella
qui ne savait pas si les propos si
Jean-Marie Le Pen était antisémite la
justice française a répondu à cette
question en condamnant Jean-Marie Le Pen
pour
antisémitisme de ce fait en mon sens le
rassemblement national n'a pas sa place
dans cette manifestation maintenant
c'est une manifestation publique à
laquelle chacun est libre en conscience
de participer ou non Olivier verrand
donc pour lui le rassemblement national
n'a pas sa place à la marche contre
l'antisémitisme je vous demander au au
chroniqueurs de bosser un peu oui ou non
Valérie qu'est-ce que tu en penses aussi
ma chérie voilà tout le monde non non
non non non je voudrais remercier Julien
odoule d'être avec nous pour vous on va
on va on va parler d'illeurs vous n
allez donner votre avis quand voyez
Olivier verérrant dire ça vous avez
envie de lui répondre quoi j'ai envie de
lui dire qu'il aurait besoin de
reprendre un petit peu de dignité de
grandir et de se mettre à la hauteur de
l'enjeu on vit une période extrêmement
difficile extrêmement troublé
particulièrement depuis le 7 octobre
pour nos compatriotes de confession
juives 7 octobre nous avons vécu le plus
effroyable massacre de juifs depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et et depuis un
mois et un jour nous avons subi dans
notre pays la France en 2023 1159 actes
antisémite tout ça évidemment appelle à
l'unité appelle à la responsabilité et
je déplore qu'un ministre de la
République soit un briseur d'unité la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme elle
appartient à aucun clan à aucun parti
politique elle ne peut pas être prise en
otage par des considérations partisanes
et nous nous considérons que c'est
l'honneur de tous les républicains quels
qu'ils soi de descendre dans la rue pour
rappeler un message clair que
l'antisémitisme la haine des Juifs n'a
pas sa place en France ne l'aura jamais
et qu'on doit faire bloc tous ensemble
c'était le message de Jordan Bardella de
Marine Le Pen et nous serons dimanche
bien évidemment au côté de tous nos
concitoyens quel que soi leurs origines
quel que soit leur religion pour dire
non à l'antisémitisme et pour faire bloc
contre les ennemis de la France qui sont
aujourd'hui les islamistes alors loï
signor merci d'être avec nousêtes
porte-parole Renaissance bonsoir on va
voir je vais vous montrer de trois
éléments aussi pour montrer voilà
pourquoi Olivier verrant aussi a dit ça
vous vous êtes d'accord avec Olivier
verrant bien entendu je vais vous
surprendre je suis d'accord avec une
partie de ce que vient dire Julien
audoule l'unité nationale elle
n'appartient à personne l'unité
nationale elle ne se décrète pas en
revanche et c'est la fin de la phrase
d'Olivier verrand chacun est libre d'y
participer en son âme et conscience et
le rassemblement national n'a pas la
conscience très propre sur ce sujet et
moi quand j'entends Jordan Bardella quel
patron de votre parti dimanche sur BFM
TV qui n'arrive pas à condamner les
propos de Jean-Marie Le Pen j'étais tout
à l'heure sur cette autre chaîne BFM TV
avec une de vos députés qui a mis une
heure 1 heure à reconnaître que
Jean-Marie Le Pen était antisémite si le
rassemblement national si Monsieur
bardellaa si Madame Le Pen parvient un
jour à dire que l'histoire du
rassemblement national que les propos de
Jean-Marie Le Pen étaient antisémite que
ce parti a été fondé par des vafess à ce
moment-là je crois que y compris la
communauté juive de France
ne pourrait pas réserver le même accueil
qu'elle a réservé à Marine Le Pen en
2018 lors de la Marche à mir knol pour
mir knol Marine Le Pen était sifflé ué
Marine Le Pen à l'élection de 2022 fait
3 % chez les Français israéliens 3%
3 % la preuve qu'il y a un problème avec
le rassemblement national faites votre
AG mient et à ce momentl peut-être que
nous pourrions parler d'unité nationale
c'est simplement la raison pour laquelle
je ne dis pas ne venez pas je dis en
votre âme et conscience changer assumer
condamner votre passé
j déjà j'ai envie de vous dire l signor
qu'il faut vous mettre à la page
l'immense majorité de nos compatriotes
de confession juive ont compris depuis
quelques années déjà que dans cet océan
de lâcheté de compromission de gens qui
ont fait semblant de les défendre mais
qui les ont livré à l'islamisme d'autres
qui ont très clairement collaboré avec
l'islam
radical du côté de la France insoumise
et et je l'assume non pas attention moi
j'assume ces proposl et je pense
majorité de
Français ces dernières semaines laisse
laissez-moi terminer je sais que ça vous
dérange si vous vouz
Mo je parle je vous parle de ce que nous
disent nos compatriotes de confession
juives qui ont peur d'emmener leurs
enfants à l'école qui ont peur de se
faire agresser dans la rue qui ont peur
de mettre une kipa qui ont peur de dire
tout simplement qu'ils sont juifs
pour pas peur du rassembl tout ça est
faux tout ça est un mensonge grotesque
qui est une menace pour les Juifs
aujourd'hui en France ce sont les
islamistes qui agresse nos compatriotes
de confession juifes dans la rue ce sont
les islamistes vous nêtes pas du côté
vous êtes contre les et
depisum
pourv depuis
2012 depuis 2012 tue des Juifs c'est
certainement pas le rassemblement
national c'est le fondamentalisme
islamiste je je dis juste à l'or qu'il
faut se mettre à la page et arrêter
cette vieille ficelle mais je sais que
c'est votre dernier argument c'est votre
seul argument que vous
recyclez sur RC desag
aujourd'hui nous sommes le rart et vous
êtes le problème alors il n'y a que des
noms personne n'est d'accord avec
Olivier ver ici autour de la table à
part à part Gilles Verdez et Valérie qui
s qui
s vous dites NON Géraldine vous êtes pas
d'accord avec Olivier moi je suis
désespéré et tout ce que j'entends c'est
désespérant je suis d'accord avec vous
monsieur je trouve que Jordan Bardella a
raté une occasion vraiment de clarifier
la situation et le passé de du
rassemblement national et s'il avait été
sans ambigué j'aurais trouvé ça beaucoup
plus courageux alors marine le Le Pen ce
matin sur R dit que son père avait eu
des propos qui l'a choqué à l'époque et
qu' en avait tiré les conséquences
d'Ille dit pas que son père éta
antisémiteous dis c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous nous
somes Mar leenifié en 2015
en Leen
an
sil plaît s'il PLA s'il vous plaît stop
pas t en même temps la raison pour
laquelle je suis choqué par la présence
du rassemblement national c'est ce que
vous venez de dire c'est que personne au
rassemblement national n'est capable de
dire oui Jean-Marie Le Pen était
antisémite est toujours d'ailles plaît
signor
justeou est-ce que comme Marine Le Pen
vous dites que Jean-Marie Le Pen a eu
des propos antisémites mais je dis comme
Marine Le Pen et comme Jordane Bardella
parce que signor à mon avis ne s'était
pas lavé les oreilles quand il a écouté
Jordan Bardella sur dans une autre
émission il a été très clair Jean-Marie
Le Pen a été condamné pour antisémitisme
voilà don donc très clairement la
justice est passée Mar
leenim j'aimerais quand même rappeler
quelque chose
queessoubl ça m'are pas
tout
Jordan Bardella est né en 1995 et les
problèmes aujourd'hui de nos
compatriotes juif et de l'antisémitisme
ne sont pas l jean-mie Le Pen qui arrêé
sa carrière politique sont li à
l'islamisme qui s'est développé dans
notre pays qui aujourd'ui est une men je
pas
pasaccordord fait d'écarter
rassemblement national de cette
manifestation parce que je su que là on
assiste à une joute politique on
nationale qui n'a aucun sens quand on
appelle un rassembl national contre
l'antisémtisme et faire croire que tous
les antisémites sont au Front national
il y a des antisémites dans tous les
partis faire croire que 30% des
personnes qui ont voté pour le rassemé
nationale sont antisémit c'est uneration
tot parti d'une manifestation a pas que
Jord
tiséutre religion é Z vous savez quand
il a dit que non mais vous l'écartez ou
pas est-ce qu'il a le bon vous répondre
avec je vais vous répondre avec des
arguments et pas par oui et non désolé
quand Éric Zemour dit que Pétin était le
sauveur des Juifs pardonnez-moi mais je
pense qu'il n'est pas le meilleur avocat
de la lutte contre l'antisémitis
certains juifs ont été choqués par cette
phrase ont été choqués aussi quand il
dit aux victimes de Mohamed Mera qu'elle
n'aurait pas dû être entré en Israël
vous rendez comptes donc les écologistes
qui invitent Médine ne peuvent pas
participer dénoncé de la même manière et
je trouve
trouveirond pas et Marine Tondelier qui
je suis d'accord avec vous en recevant
mdine lors de ses universités d'été de
rentrée je me suis exprimé à l'époque
sur le sujet a participé oui à une forme
d'antisémitisme et oui je trouve qu'elle
aurait dû prononcer des excuses plus
franches et dimanche elle n'a pas
totalement sa place tant qu'elle n'aura
pas elle aussi dit que c'était une
erreur de je je non mais je ne juge pas
l'ensemble de la classe politique à
l'hône de son passé je dis simplement je
dis simplement je dis simplementéch
regardez ce qu'il
dit il n pas sa place il n' pas
place pas que nous les républains sont
un partie qui n'ont pas été dans une
comomission
avec citoy je ne rejette pas la présence
des électeurs de Marine Le Pen même si
je pense qu'elle leur m et qu'elle les
trompe je les soupçonne pas comme je
vous soupon
pas l'homme politique ne trompe pas s'il
vous plaît non c'est vrai les les
promesses d'homme politique voilà c'est
un peu Daniel moi je suis écuré depuis
l'annonce de cette marche je suis écurée
par cette vous savez du CP Moretti a dit
la poloche ben c'est exactement ça vous
êtes tous en train de faire de la petite
peloche et alors toi tu as le droit de
rentrer toi tu as pas le droit de
rentrer déjà j'aimerais bien savoir si
Marine Le Pen et Jean-Luc Mélenchon
viennent à cette manifestation qui sera
le plusé des des deux déjà ça serait
intéressant de voir ça donc comme a dit
Jean-Michel l'antisémitisme il est
partout c'est c'est quelque chose de
grave c'est une cause où vraiment c'est
si on n pas tous la main dans la main
dimanche c'est foutu ça cette
manifestation ne servira à rien quand on
voit la dignité de de la maman et du
frère de cet otage les les familles
d'otage ont besoin de de cette unité
tout le monde a besoin de cette unité et
vous êtes en train de vous renvoyer des
propos d'un monsieur de 95 ans non mais
moi je suis équeuré
excusez-moi
remtion pas Jean-M Le Pen député du
rassemblement national avec laquelle
j'ai changé tout à l'heure compar le
droit à l'avortement des femmes à la ch
pardon le
remblp
actu vous faites de la petite politique
Politien ex a de r rtionut faire si la
filleut contred le
père laiss
faire et j'aimerais vous rappeler
quelque chose comme à Olivier ver
puisque vous avez l'air de croire que
l'antisémitisme et l'exclusivité de la
droite et de l'extrême droite vous
devriez lire vivorka et l'istoire de la
gauche vous avez lu vivor est-ce que
vous savez que votre père spirituel jor
était lui-même antisémite que vous en
savez je me suis déjà je me suis déjà
onent sur toutes leses l'idéeon laqu la
droite et l'extrme droiteur
l'exclusivité de
l'É hisor lisez vivor
liseimportant c'est un fait important ce
que je veux dire c'est que balayons tout
ça parce que personne n'oubliera les
propos de Jean-Marie Le Pen évidemment
qu'il a été antisémite il a été condamné
trois fois pour
çaoup le vous raison c'est plus à la
page 202 candidat du Rassemblement
nationaln desourui les jees nous our
vous
syst
N
manifestation ce qui est absolument
insupportable c'est que tout le monde
instrumentalise tout le monde
c'est-à-dire que le rassemblement
national est très très heureux d'être là
pour se faire une sorte de washing
incroyable en train de dire que regardez
nous sommes nous sommes le paravant et
et et vous vous mettez vous les Juifs de
France derrière nous parce que nous nous
serons un rempart et et nous allons vous
protéger alors qu'on connaît l'histoire
de ce parti de l'autre côté de l'autre
côté de l' chiquier on a l'extrême
gauche qui elle aussi fait son le
paravant en disant oui mais attention
nous nous sommes le paravant enfin c'est
absolument insupportable un peu de
dignité il s'agit là d'une manifestation
qui est censée être une manifestation
républicaine sur un thème qui devrait
rassembler l'ensemble des Français peu
importe leur couleurs politique peu
importe leur religion il s'agit d'une
lutte contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme bon s est-ce que pour
une fois on pourrait arrêter de faire ce
qu'a dit Daniel c'estàdire de la petite
politique de bas étage qui n ne grandit
personne dans un moment où devrait y
avoir la concorde nationale c'est
insupportable euh Delphine bravo Valérie
ouis oui bravo Valée
je suis je suis tout à fait d'accord je
trouve que c'est la foire en fait à la
mauvaise foi ces derniers temps je
trouve que c'est pathétique je trouve
que c'est pathétique d'utiliser cette
guerre effectivement de
d'instrumentaliser pour encore une fois
diaboliser le rassemblement national
comme vous le faites depuis des années
sauf que depuis des années il est au
second tour au bout d'un moment faudra
bien l'accepter parce que les Français
sont en colère et je trouve que cette
marche de l'antisémitisme ça veut
surtout dire la marche pour la paitisme
contre l'antisémitisme pardon ça veut
surtout dire la marche pour la paix
merci et je pense enfin
qui qui êtes-vous pour dire un tel ou un
tel n'a pas le droit de venir c'est une
cohésion nationale avec tous les partis
de France moi je le rassemblement
national fait partie légitime et partie
intégrante de de ce qui est proposé
aujourd'hui en France et ce depuis des
années en fait donc qui êtes-vous pour
dire ceux qui ne viennent pas est-ce que
vous êtes portier de la boîte ou c'est
quoi je dis simplement aujourd'hui au
rassemblement national de dire les
choses plus clairement à la fois sur son
histoire sur son passé et sur son
présent et comme je le rappelais des
candidats à chaque élection sont exclus
pour avoir tenu des propos antisémites
quand vous avez 39 % dans un soage en
2022 des électeurs du rassemblement
national qui estime je cite que les
Juifs ont trop de pouvoir dans le
domaine de l'économie et de la finance
moi personnellement cela me choque et je
ne dis pas au rassemblement national de
ne pas venir ils viendront ils viendront
dans une démarche politicienne ils ont
répondu à l'appel de yel Bron Pivet et
desgérard Larché au bout d'une minute
sur les réseaux sociaux pour dire nous
serons présents preuve que cela les
arrange bien surtout quelques jours
après la bourde et l'erreur monument
commise Jordan en ne parvenant pas à
condamner les propos antisémites de
Jean-Marie Le Pen vous faites de la
politique je ne vous interdis pas de
veniremtion question
vousé les persones depu anné
mett
er faites de lati et trompz par la VI le
des années 80 o consiste à marginaliser
un parti au lieu au contraire d'en
parler vousez très
bienès
bien pas seul Gill Verdez et en plus
ple je vais le faire parler voilà non
non laissez parler Gilles Verdez qui est
bien senciux pour une fois ou mal
accompagné mercii qui vous connais bien
vous connaissez moi j'ai pris la
question pour moi c'est-à-dire êtes-vous
d'accord avec Olivier verérrant est-ce
que vous marcheriez au côté d'élu du
rassemblement national à cette marche
ben non monsieur Odou moi je marche pas
avec vous parce que vous aviez une
occasion historique effectivement de
rompre avec ce passé qui est terrible
les chambres à gaz un point de détail du
Rafour crématoire tout Jean-Marie Le Pen
et tout vous revient là et c'est mérité
pour vous il fallait rompre avec ça si
vous
rompiez moi je vous le dis j'aurais pu
marcher j'aurais pu marcher avec vos
électeurs certainement même peut-être
avec vous mais là non et là moi je
trouve que vous êtes hypocrite parce que
vous faites vous ramassez la mise
politiquement sur le dos de cette marche
et c'est pas bien ce que vous faites
avec plaisir ave plaisir c'est ce qu' a
dit le rassemblement national c'est 13
millions de francs
Marine Le Pen est arrivé au second tour
avec 42 % c'est 88 députés qui sont tout
à fait légitimes qui ont été élus
démocratiquement c'est aujourd'hui des
millions de Français qui se
reconnaissent dans nos idées et ne vous
en déplaise c'est aussi des millions de
nos compatriotes de confession juive je
suis député à l'Assemblée nationale je
suis vice-président du groupe d'amitié
franceisraël voilà je pense que Marine
Le Pen Jordan Bardella moi-même tous mes
collègues ont été extrêmement clairs
depuis des années Marine Le Pen en 2010
a été l'une des premières à dire que
dans des quartiers de France il ne
faisait pas bon être juif être femme ou
même être français ça a été la première
à le dire elle a été insultée pour ça
très clairement et aujourd'hui on nous
refuserait une marche républicaine une
marche d'unité mais très clairement
est-ce qu'il ne faudrait pas rassembler
tous les Français est-ce que c'est pas
le sens de la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme est-ce que je reproche à
des diviseurs comme monsieur verérrant
qui fait véritablement de la politique
Politi et j'allais dire de la politique
bassement politicienne c'est qu'il fait
le jeu de nos ennemis il fait le jeu de
tous les antisémites qui voit que nous
sommes divisés sur le sujet que les
Français la France on n'est pas capable
d'avoir un message d'unité sur une cause
aussi sensible aussi grave rendez-vous
compte 1159 actes antisémite en un mois
mais c'est intolérable vous avez des
Français de confessions juif qui ont
peur chaque jour est-ce que ça mér pas
rement et l'unité quel que soit
al on vair sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon hier
soir jeanluc Mélenchon eximé déjà son
mécent